يطلقون الصواريخ لن لن اقدم تفاصيل ولن
نستخدم المنصه هذه للخوض في هذا الامر
الان نعتقد ان وقف اطلاق النار سيفيد
حماس من الصعب التعليق على هذا الامر انها
الارض التي يعيش عليها الفلسطينيون انها
ارضهم ارضهم التاريخيه النواب الامريكي
اسرائيل تتطلب الان اهتماما اكثر من دعم
اوكرانيا البحريه الامريكيه تتحرك باتجاه
الشرق الاوسط ومصر تهدد بقطع العلاقات مع
تل ابيب مستشفيات فلسطين تستغيث بالقاهره
مستشار ترامب يصرح اذا اندلعت حرب اقليميه
فلن تبقى هناك اسرائيل في النهايه اسرائيل
تضع خيارين امام المقاومه الفلسطينيه
الرئيس الجزائري يدافع عن الفلسطينيين
امام العالم الضربات العراقيه تمطير
القواعد الامريكيه روسيا تعلن الا شتاء
دافيا للاوروبيين
والمانيا تتحضر عسكريا عشرات العائلات
الاوكرانيه تلجا للسلطات الروسيه الدفاع
الروسيه تصرح بارقام فلكيه لخسائر الهجوم
الاوكراني المضاد وبكين تستعد للتعاون مع
موسكو رسميا تدخل
امريكي تعقدت الامور في فلسطين وتداخلت
القضايا فيما بينها لتختلط اوراق الحلفاء
والاعداء لتعلن شبكه سي ان ال ان
الامريكيه نقلا عن مسؤولين امريكيين ان
قوه من الرد السريع التابعه لمشاه البحريه
الامريكيه توجهت باتجاه شرق البحر المتوسط
في الوقت نفسه نفت واشنطن اي نيه لارسال
قوات بريه الى اسرائيل او غزه لتخرج نائبه
الرئيس الامريكي كمالا هاريس وتقول ان
واشنطن ليس لها خطط لارسال قوات الى
اسرائيل او قطاع غزه واوضحت هارس لقناه سي
بي اس ان الولايات المتحده تزود اسرائيل
بالمشوره والمعدات والدعم الدبلوماسي في
حربها على قطاع غزه فيما حضر مستشار ترامب
السابق والعقيد المتقاعد دوجلاس مكريجر من
اختفاء اسرائيل حال اندلاع حرب اقليميه في
المنطقه قائلا لقناه ريديك على موقع
يوتيوب خوفي الاكبر هو انه اذا اندلعت حرب
اقليميه فلن تبقى هناك اسرائيل في النهايه
هناك علق رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي
الجديد مايك جونسون على طلب الرئيس جو
بايدن تقديم حزمه مساعده واحده لاسرائيل
واوكرانيا قائلا ان اسرائيل تتطلب الان
اهتماما اكثر من دعم كياف بحسب فوكس نيوز
لتتواصل هنا المواقف الدوليه نحو حرب غزه
حيث اجرى رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريتشرد
سوناك مكالمه هاتفيه مع الرئيس الفرنسي
امانويل ماكرون شدد خلالها على اهميه
ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه الى قطاع غزه
من جهته قال رئيس وزراء النرويج يوناس جار
ستور ان رد فعل الجيش الاسرائيلي في قطاع
غزه على الهجوم الذي شنته المقاومه غير
مكافئ للفعل منددا بالوضع الانساني
الكارثي في القطاع اما في مصر فذكرت قناه
اي 24 نيوز الاخباريه الاسرائيليه ان
القاهره حذرت تلبيب من القيام باي عمليه
عسكريه في المنطقه العازله على ممر
فيلادلفيا بين مصر وقطاع غزه واوضحت
القناه ان مصر هددت بان استمرار هذا الامر
قد يؤدي للحد من العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين
البلدين خلال ذلك كشفت فضائيه اكسترا نيوز
المصريه عن وجود ترتيبات مصريه من اجل
ادخال 60 شاحنه محمله بالمساعدات
الانسانيه المختلفه الى قطاع غزه ليعلن
مكتب الامم المتحده ان 33 شاحنه مساعدات
الانسانيه كانت قد دخلت للقطاع عبر معبر
رفح فيما كان المتحدث باسم وزاره الصحه
الفلسطين نشد الاشقاء في مصر فتح معبر رفح
للسماح بدخول المساعدات الطبيه في الجزائر
قال الرئيس عبد المجيد تبون ان
الفلسطينيين ليسوا ارهابيين ولم يكونوا
كذلك بل يدافعون عن حقهم واستقلال وطنهم
مضيفا ان ما يحدث في غزه جرائم حرب وجرائم
ضد الانسانيه مكتمله الاركان لننتقل الى
الاجواء العمليه البريه الاسرائيليه في
قطاع غزه حيث تم بث تسجيل المحتجزات
اسرائيليات في غزه يوجهنا رساله الى رئيس
الحكومه الاسرائيليه بنيامين نتنياهو
وقالت المحتجزات في التسجيل نعلم انه كان
هناك مطلب لوقف اطلاق النار وكان من
المفترض ان تطلقنا جميعا كنت ملزما باطلاق
سراحنا جميعا وبدلا من ذلك نحن نعاني من
عجزك السياسي والامني والعسكري
والدبلوماسي ليرد نتنياهو ان هذا الفيديو
دعايه نفسيه قاسيه هناك قالت شبكه ان بي
سي امريكيه ان المفاوضات بشان الافراج عن
بعض المحتجزين في قطاع غزه تعثرت وذلك بعد
ان اشترطت حركه المقاومه السماحه بدخول
الوقود اولا الى غزه ميدانيا نفى رئيس
المكتب الاعلامي لحكومه غزه سلامه معروف
توغل الجيش الاسرائيلي في الاحياء السكنيه
بالقطاع مشيرا ان بضع دبابات توغلت حتى
شارح صلاح الدين الرئيسي والذي يفصل شمال
القطاع عن جنوبه وان فصائل المقاومه
اجبرتها على التراجع في الحصيله اعلنت
وزاره الصحه في غزه عن ارتفاع عدد ضحايا
القصف الاسرائيلي على القطاع منذ السابع
من الشهر الجاري الى
8306 قتلى غالبيتهم من النساء والاطفال
والشيوخ ليصرح وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي اف
جالانت خلال مؤتمر صحفي بان امام ارهابي
حماس الموت او الاستسلام فقط ولا يوجد
خيار اخر وتابع حول مقاومه لبنان ان من
سيجبرنا الى الحرب سيدفع ثمنا كبيرا
قواتنا جاهزه للرد على اي عدوان من الشمال
واكد ان الحرب على غزه لن تكون قصيره في
الحدود اللبنانيه استهدفت القوات
الاسرائيليه بالقذائف المدفعيه محيط موقع
الراهب واطراف بلده عيتا الشعب كما قصفت
بالقنابل الحارقه
والمضيئة الاسلحه المناسبه وحققت اصابات
مباشره فيها بعيدا عن اجواء المعارك
ارتفعت اسعار الغاز في اوروبا مع زياده
المخاوف على امدادات الوقود الازرق الى
السوق الاوروبيه وخاصه بعد توقف صادرات
الغاز الاسرائيليه الى مصر وافادت وكاله
بلومبرج بان الاسواق تتخوف من توسع
المواجهه في منطقه الشرق الاوسط لتشمل جهه
جديده في العراق اعلنت المقاومه استهداف
القاعده الامريكيه في حقل غاز كونيكو ريف
دير الزور الشمالي برشقه صاروخيه واصابه
اهدافها بشكل مباشر موسكو تشهر سلاحها
امام اوروبا ان لم تكن معي فلا تكن ضدي
جمله تطبقها روسيا حرفيا امام اوروبا
والغرب خلال الحرب الاوكرانيه هنا قال
نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي ديمتري
ميدفيدف انه لا يمكن لاحد ان يضمن توفير
شتاء دافئ للمواطنين الاوروبيين في الفصل
القادم وا ضف فل يعزوا انفسهم بانهم اخيرا
تخلصوا والى الابد من اعتمادهم على الطاقه
القادمه من روسيا المكروهه ليدعو وزير
الدفاع الالماني بوريس بوستوس الى تبني
منطق جديد في المجتمع لمواجهه الازمات
كتلك التي يشهدها الشرق الاوسط محذرا من
خطر الحرب في اوروبا وقال بوريس انه يجب
ان تكون المانيا قادره على الدفاع عن
نفسها وهو ما ينطبق على الجيش الالماني
والمجتمع واكد على ض ان تصبح المانيا
مؤهله للحرب على ارض الميدان اعلنت وزاره
الخارجيه الروسيه ان عشرات العائلات
الاوكرانيه لجئت للبعثه الروسيه لدى الامم
المتحده خلال الاشهر السته الماضيه طالبه
مساعده في استعاده اطفالها الذين اخذهم
الغرب ليعلن وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجي
شويو ان خسائر القوات الاوكرانيه خلال
هجومها المضاد تجاوزت 90 الف فرد بين قتيل
وجريح دون تحقيق نجاحات على الارض بينما
اعلن الجيش الاوكراني انه ضرب بنجاح
منظومه للدفاع الجوي الروسي في شبه جزيره
القرم من جهتها اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه اسقاط ثمانيه صواريخ ستورم شادو
بريطانيه مجنحه اطلقتها قوات كياف على
اهداف في شبه جزيره القرم الروسيه وبين
هذا وذاك اعرب نائب رئيس المجلس العسكري
المركزي لجمهوريه الصين تشانجو تشيا عن
استعداد بلاده للعمل مع روسيا للرد على
مختلف التحديات الامنيه والحفاظ على
التوازن الاستراتيجي والاستقرار
[موسيقى]